now we're coming towards the end of
surface area we've looked at lots of
different kinds of shapes think back to
last week what was the first kind of the
simplest kind of shape that we've worked
out the surface area Oh hands up if any
one of them resumes okay I've had it
very good
we went from prisms which had a similar
cross-section all the way through it to
another one the start of P pyramids very
good which don't have the same
cross-section they have a base and then
obviously comes up to the point we did
prisons we did periods yes the day we
looked at two kinds of shapes we looked
at spheres and code I suppose you could
think of a cone kind of like a special
pyramid right that's what we left off
composit solids take all those ideas and
roll them into one because does anyone
know what opposite means yeah very good
it's whenever you combine things of any
kind like for example you can have
composite materials like polyester made
one plastic and cotton mixed together
well we're talking about composite
solids maybe you want to draw one of
these next to one where you've got
you're working here only has to be small
things like say this
he's a druid upside down he's an ice
cream cone right so you've got the huh
you have the waffle there and then you
have the ice cream this is a kind of a
hemisphere put together yeah yes why
aren't we doing a practical example ah
well work Health and Safety and allergy
safety that's that's why I'm not doing
anything so here's an example two solids
you already know how to find the surface
area of a Antigua
you can do this very thing for example
if we took a cube a simple cube right
away I could turn this into a
composition is not by adding something
on but I could take something away for
instance if I punched a hole in here
right it was a triangular prism all the
way through
okay can you picture it can you imagine
a block right and then someone is chisel
all the way through so you have this
whole going right down the middle
in the shape further right okay so in
each of these I want to give you three
principles that will help you with all
kinds of composites columns like this
and then I'll come back to these two
specific shapes ok so here are my three
principles and they kind of overlap with
things you've already done number one
you're dealing with shapes right and
there are pictures you might be provided
with a picture you might not they might
be a verbal description whatever the
case is the first thing you should
always do is your diagrams now I'll add
on to something once you've got the
diagram there but this is so important
like I said even when you've been
provided a diagram there isn't someone
to draw is because when you write and
when you draw as a mathematician okay
you do that for two main reasons the
first one who is like over here have a
look at this the first one is you want
to present your mathematical thinking to
someone else right
it's like stuffs in my hand I want to
get it out of my head and into yours
that's what writing and drawing helps us
do now that I've got this yup that's the
picture from my mind to yours see you're
communicating okay but in addition to
that we're right and we draw not just to
communicate mathematically but to
construct it have a look at this first
equation that you got right I cannot
solve that in my head I just can't do it
right even if you give me lots and lots
of time all I've got is my brain I know
I might be able to get through here but
I don't think I've got the right answer
so we don't just communicate
mathematical thought through writing a
drawing we actually construct
mathematical form by writing in joy as
you draw this you understand the shape
the act of drawing tops your attention
so once you've drawn it there are a few
things we're going to include on there
in addition to just the diagram I would
encourage you
to add do you remember on that pyramid
we were working out just mount it excuse
me to do the surface area I added on
extra wines we call them constructions
far more easy to add constructions when
you've got a thing on a piece of paper
rather than in your head on your head
and then when you have constructions
usually you need to know like legs or
ankles or whatever it is so we call them
measurements so your diagrams they serve
a purpose they help you add stuff on and
also know what numbers are there now
secondly I'll just have a look at say
this guy here oh right do you remember a
couple of days ago I asked you about
this weed cross-shaped prism and I said
hey how many phases are there right
that's the question I posed how many
phases wrought this as a rhetorical
question I shouldn't you think about it
but do you notice as you count them
through I count six they're to be on the
cube on the outside but then as I've
touched through an atom a few more I
think I count nine now as you've got
those of your head and then are
communicating what those sub-series
ah you've got to be able to talk about
what's what top bottom side inside etc
so therefore on your diagram you should
name or label what we call those things
that I was going up the faces right
because that enables you to actually
talk about what they are and have them
in your working rather than just like a
series of equations that may give you
the right number but I don't know what
they're talking about
I don't know they're referring to so
they will able to face it and do it on
the diagram do something like if you've
drawn this you know top
front inside sometimes it's a bit tricky
you might have lots of different things
they like either I've run out of words
maybe just knocking at their faces side
face 1 2 3 4 whatever you need to so
that there's an unambiguous way to refer
to them
yeah that's a great question the answer
to your specific one I would assume is
yes when we say surface area when we say
service area we literally mean the
entire surface so if you've got cup
right you picture clapping you might
write the inside where you pull water
that is part of the surface of the cup
so it would be included which is why if
it's closed
well the surface is just the outside
part which I don't worry about the
investment okay here it's just a hole so
in this case I'd included okay
lastly it's just sort of feeding off of
this second principle what's you labeled
those faces you should identify those
faces in all of those equations and
calculations that you're doing down here
okay see all of this stuff this may all
be numerically correct but I don't
really know what any of it refers to
like what is 4860 what is the signified
I'm guessing now it's the four
triangular faces by linking at that and
try to work it out I think that's what's
going on so just tell me that's what
you're doing communicate clearly so
identify the faces in your work okay so
before we actually do an example
together so maybe if you have already
open up your laptops and word up to
exercise four or five as you're doing
that can I just get you to have one eye
as well on this one I've only just
noticed this because I talked about it
the one where I said I'll look you've
got a pyramid and there's four
triangular faces 4860 may well be the
correct number as you all agreed with
that number
however just be really really careful as
you're opening it please look at what
I'm about to write on the board just
look carefully I wonder if you can
follow the train of thought
I practiced this for years which is why
I know what's going on but that line
actually has a really big problem with
it
I think if I'm reading this correctly I
think 1/2 times 45 times 54 I think
that's what doesn't you hundred even if
day you can go ahead and you can check
ok now then this happens now can you
tell me why right or wrong can you tell
me why this appears yeah very good
you're like my weight got one time but
then actually I've got four of them okay
so that's why you end up with the right
number 1860 so can anyone tell me why
it's a problem to write it like this
arash it's that guy right there when you
say something equals something else
really mean they are identical in every
way and their values and their magnitude
etc and once we put this in they're no
longer equal 1/2 time point 5 9 54 is
not this number no you want this number
but if you want that maybe you should
say I've got four triangles to begin
with and then everything is actually so
just a minor